Speaker 1: We are going to do a full review
today of CPAC 2023, the Conservative Political
Action Conference happening in Washington,
D.C., under the cloud of sexual assault charges
against its organizer, Matt SCHLAPP.
Now, Donald Trump closed out the speech on
Saturday, delivering what I believe is his
most dangerous and unhinged speech, yet closing
out what is not only a deplorable conference,
but a conference that really gave me confidence
that Donald Trump is still in control of the
loudest wing of the Republican Party and he
is the candidate to beat in the 2024 Republican
primary.
After everything that's happened, after everything
we've been through, his presidency losing
in 2020, spending years, claiming it was rigged,
announcing he's running 2020 for all of it.
Trump showed up and gave one of the scariest
and most delusional authoritarian speeches
that he has ever given.
And that is saying a lot because he's given,
what, hundreds, thousands of these speeches.
Impossible to fact check hundreds of lies.
Why Trump swollen?
We never know.
His right eye almost completely swollen, shut
going a nearly to Castro like hours in length.
A couple of glitches.
It wasn't the glitziest speech, but Trump
stumbling once again with United States.
Speaker 2: The racist Manhattan District attorney
Alvin Bragg, who is presiding over one of
the most dangerous and violent cities in the
United States.
Speaker 1: The United Straights and Trump
continuing to struggle with states later,
calling them Speight's.
Speaker 2: Wonderful, beautiful.
And I'll challenge the governors of all 50
states.
Speaker 1: That's right.
If you are currently governing any of the
states, Trump is coming for you.
One other funny moment before we get into
the scary part.
The speech briefly interrupted by someone
playing really loud music and then protesters
started to boot our country.
I'm sorry that has Trump's fans started to
boo the guy playing the loud music.
Speaker 2: Well, they love our country have
been so great on that issue.
And the perverts who use the names of Washington
and Lincoln to buy millions of dollars in
ads to say bad, libelous things about us.
Speaker 1: So Trump yelling over the music
and the people yelling at the music guy.
All right.
So a couple of funny moments, but then it
got very scary and very dishonest.
Just a sampling of lies.
Donald Trump said that while he was president,
he finished some wars, which I couldn't.
I'm not aware of Trump ending any wars.
Speaker 2: The only president in modern history
who did not have any new wars.
No new wars.
I finished some old.
Speaker 1: Some of the fact checkers aren't
able to find any wars that Donald Trump finished.
A big theme of the speech, Trump going hard
at Republicans, of course, going after the
leftist Marxist, communist, socialist, of
course, but going very aggressively against
Republicans, signaling this is going to be
a disgustingly chippy and dirty primary.
Here is Trump calling out Mitch McConnell.
Speaker 2: And, you know, we all want to see
success, but it's far more important to them
than it is to us because of that location.
We are never going to be a country ruled by
entrenched political dynasties in both parties,
rotten with special interest, China loving
politicians, of which there are many.
You're listening to this, Mitch McConnell,
Are you listening?
Speaker 1: And the crowd liking the Civil
War friendly fire.
Speaker 2: And a militant left wing news media
that's either frightened of telling the truth
or is truly evil and bad.
I don't know.
Speaker 1: Yeah, Trump doesn't know.
Trump then spending more time going after
Jeb Bush and Karl Rove and Paul Ryan.
A lot of friendly fire here.
Speaker 2: When we started this journey, a
journey like there has never been before,
there's never been anything like this.
We had a Republican Party that was ruled by
freaks, neocons, globalist, open borders,
zealots and fools.
But we are never going back to the party of
Paul Ryan, Karl Rove, and Jeb Bush.
Speaker 1: And Trump is honest in the sense
that if he is going to have a shot, the Republican
Party can't go back to Paul Ryan, Karl Rove
and Jeb Bush because if they did Trump, Trump
would be out on his ass, quite frankly.
Donald Trump seemed to suggest that he really
believed many of the people who back in 2020
told him, Listen, you're going to be back
in the Oval Office in six weeks less.
Speaker 2: Used to say four years.
A lot of people said, well, sir, the election
was so bad, you'll be in in one year.
A lot of people in this room, you'll be back
in six weeks.
But it's a bad system in many ways.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
It's a system that doesn't have a process
for reinstating a president after someone
else has been president for six weeks.
That's what Trump is bemoaning.
We've got a bad process.
You know, people came to me, sir.
They said they were crying.
They said, Sir, you'll be back in five weeks.
Biden's so bad.
And then our system wouldn't allow it.
Trump found out.
That's right.
We don't have a system.
We have a line of succession that goes from
the president to the vice president to the
secretary of state and then on down to it
doesn't affect Speaker of the House.
It doesn't actually go to the guy who lost
the last election.
That is true.
That is not the system that we have.
Trump then talking about the wall and this
is the moment at which Trump's sanity was
most questioned.
Trump seems to say that they hit the wall.
Biden took the border wall with Mexico and
he hid it somewhere so that it wouldn't be
used to.
Speaker 2: Wall was sitting there waiting
to be installed.
The easiest part and Biden they took it away
so that Texas and Arizona couldn't use it.
Texas and Arizona said, could we use that
wall?
We'll finish it right up.
And they said, no.
And they actually took it away and they hid
it.
They put it in a hiding area, which, of course,
was revealed pretty quickly when you introduced
that a couple of helicopters up.
That's right.
But they wouldn't let them use it under my
leadership.
Speaker 1: What on earth is this guy talking
about?
They hid the wall.
They moved the wall and hid it.
But then with some helicopters, Trump figured
out where Biden hid his border wall.
This is delusional stuff.
I can't think of a charitable interpretation
of what on earth Trump is talking about.
Then Trump, using really strange language,
talked about baby bonuses.
Now there is actually a policy connection
here.
Let me first play for you the deranged insanity
that Trump said, but then I want to say more
about it.
Speaker 2: The governors of all 50 states,
all 50 states to join me in a great beautification
campaign, we will rename our schools and boulevards
not after communists, but after great American
patriots.
Right.
We will get rid of bad and ugly buildings
and return to the magnificent classical style
of Western civilization.
While we will support baby boomers and we
will support baby bonuses for the new baby
boomers.
Does that sound That sounds pretty.
I want a baby boom.
Speaker 1: So what's interesting about this
is, on the one hand, it's very reminiscent
of Hitler's mother's Cross, which was a program
to encourage Germans to have kids.
But on the other hand, there's this thing
called the child tax credit, which Joe Biden
and Democrats would like to make permanent
a higher tax credit for children, which in
a way is kind of what Trump is talking about,
although the child tax credit isn't to encourage
people to have children, it's to provide financial
support for those who do.
But Republicans are against making that permanent.
So it's all just a weird mishmash, sort of
a verbal inkblot test of sorts.
Trump also taking shots not only at Republicans
but at Fox News during this deranged speech,
which, by the way, carried the speech.
Speaker 2: Not too good.
And we actually and I have to say this, I
hope Fox doesn't turn off, but we did much
better in 2020 than we did in 2016.
Speaker 1: Right.
I mean, you did.
Speaker 2: But we have no choice.
Speaker 1: Not in the sense that you lost
anyway.
Donald Trump, again, reviving this idea of
sending people addicted to drugs and who just
are homeless to tent cities, sort of like
camps of sorts.
Remember, they would always accuse Barack
Obama, he's going to send you to a camp.
Trump, quite literally, is saying that's what
he wants to do.
Take a listen.
Oh, no.
Looks like this particular clip may be glitching.
Let's see if I if I can fix that for my audience
here.
I do believe that I can.
I have confidence that I can.
Here we go.
Speaker 2: Leadership.
We will take the homeless, drug addicted and
severely deranged, get them off our streets
and create tent cities where we will get them
the help they so desperately need.
Right.
Speaker 1: And the crowd reacting pretty positively
to that.
Trump also wrongly claiming, by the way, that
so-called foreign mental institutions and,
quote, insane asylums are being emptied into
the United States.
That's not happening, by the way.
Speaker 2: They're emptying out their prisons.
And you've heard me say that.
But they're also emptying out their mental
institutions and want to use a strong couple
of words, insane asylum, insane asylum.
That's where anybody see Silence of the Lambs.
That's where they come from.
Speaker 1: Silence of the Lambs has been emptied.
Anthony Hot Basically undocumented immigrant
versions of Anthony Hopkins are just being
released into the country.
None of that is going on.
Just so people know.
Trump at one point asks whether anyone has
watched TV and everybody.
Speaker 2: You ever see television?
You know, it used to be.
We'd build our military.
We were proud of that.
We'd be doing all things would be all you
see, I think.
Investigation, investigation, investigation.
Now, with that being said, you got to look
at Hunter.
I mean, how crooked is that deal?
Speaker 1: But right now, and often going
back to the topic of Hunter Biden and then
Donald Trump talking about with really, really
strange language, how he is the retribution,
he is now talking about retribution and revenge.
This was maybe the most dictatorial moment
of the speech other than like 40 other moments
that were almost as dictatorial.
Speaker 2: In 2016.
I declared, I am your voice today.
I and I am your warrior.
I am your justice.
And for those who have been wronged and betrayed,
I am your retribution.
Speaker 1: I don't even think Trump knows
what he's talking about.
He wrote something people told him, but it's
really, really scary dystopian stuff.
Trump at one point on a very strange word,
salad about oil and gas and electric vehicles.
Speaker 2: We have oil and gas, but we don't
want the oil and gas cars.
But we want everything, including electric
cars.
But we also want gasoline because the cars
go longer.
Oh, and their preferred by many people.
Speaker 1: Pretty crystal clear position,
huh?
Speaker 2: We don't like quick drives at a
stop for two and a half hours.
Speaker 1: Yep.
Trump is not pleased with the range of electric
vehicles and then Trump bringing out the L
word lynching, saying that they are looking
to lynch him.
Of course, he is the ultimate victim, as many
of you know.
And unfortunately, another very glitchy clip
here.
I don't know what is causing these glitches,
and I hate to ever be unprepared for my audience.
But a couple a couple of glitchy clips here.
Let's continue.
Speaker 2: Amazing.
What the hell did you get me into?
Unidentified: Yeah.
I didn't know the word subpoena.
Speaker 2: I didn't hear the word grand jury.
Those words.
Grand jury.
I didn't know that.
They want to lynch you for doing nothing wrong.
I didn't know they want to lynch you for doing
a great job.
I didn't know they want to put you away because
your poll numbers are better than anybody
they've seen in years.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
Trump's best poll numbers.
So a few thoughts about this speech.
Obviously, Trump telling hundreds of lies,
delusional, dangerous, authoritarian.
One notable thing from Trump's very long speech
is that while he did attack Paul Ryan and
Mitch McConnell and Karl Rove and Jeb Bush
and RINOs, he didn't overtly go after any
of the 2024 Republican contenders or would
be contenders like DeSantis.
He didn't even allude to DeSantis in this
particular speech.
That's interesting and unclear what the strategy
there is.
Trump did make claims that CPAC was packed.
Trump's speech was the most full of any of
the events, and it was only about 85% full.
Many of the other events very much empty.
And then another thing is the crowd really
didn't seem that energized.
NBC News as Benjamin Goggin tweeted a picture
and said, As Trump's speech bleeds over to
the one hour mark, a notable number of people
are filtering out.
Matt Gaetz slipped out early, shaking hands
in the aisle.
Energy tonight is much sleepier than last
year's Trump CPAC speech.
I am increasingly convinced that Donald Trump
as the Republican nominee is the best thing
for Democrats, particularly after seeing this
speech.
I will talk more about that tomorrow.
Let's now move on to a few other things.